john lynch now getting the reward right
this is how it goes we talked about it
with the bears if you don't get it done
you're gone if you get it done you get
rewarded you get security you get
financial compensation
and they're they're look good news
lynch shanahan both under contract for
five years the little awkward part of
this it looks like kyle's got one more
year of security than john lynch not
that that matters they're together it's
working well and anytime you have guys
that are signed up at least five years
into the future that's as much stability
as anyone can hope for other than john
gruden who got a 10-year deal right but
the gm doesn't have a 10-year deal so uh
hey they're making it work they're
finding the right players they're
finding the players that fuel that
mentality that you need to make their
offense go chris and their defense be
successful and i think it's a great
parent because i think lynch has that
eye for guys that were like his
teammates in tampa bay and lynch uh does
that and shanahan has the eye for what
he needs offensively and it's working
that's exact exactly right it's a great
combination it really is you know we
know you know john lynch first off hey
there was a lot of people i don't know
can he be a gm blah blah blah you know
and i know we both were like yeah of
course he can i mean i know i argued for
sure just going he knows what a good
three technique looks like oh warren
sapp he knows what a good dn looks like
oh simeon rice he knows what a good
linebacker looks like oh derek brooks
you know he's been around it so yeah i'm
sure he had to adjust to you know the
scouting lifestyle and figuring out how
to do his draft board and things like
that he probably needed somebody to help
him but he knows what a damn good
football player looks like and then
shanahan you know that's where it's a
great combination to me mike a little
bit of what you said shanahan has a
vision for his offense he knows the
specific style of player he likes at
each position and he could tell john
lynch that and then why kyle's coaching
the football team john can be looking at
film scouting guys going ooh this is
what kyle likes a guard oh this is what
kind of receiver kyle likes and then
okay we've dwindled it down to four or
five guys now kyle and you know kyle and
john can sit in a room and start to
discuss which of the five guys they like
the best and that's where it's it's
working beautifully for them right now
and i don't understand the five or six
year thing either but either way like
you said there's some security there
they're both awesome at their job and
you know i expect big things from the
49ers
yeah look if if you have the ability
to
look at all of the potential guys
available in the draft and find the guys
that you think are going to work in your
system that are going to flourish in
your system they're going to develop
into the guys who become the
cornerstones i mean what what with
george kiddo a fourth rounder yeah so i
mean if you you can find those guys and
and chris we talked about this last year
as the 49ers were thriving throughout
the regular season into the postseason
when you have the limited
padded practices when you have reduced
contact when you have not the same
opportunity to teach guys how to tackle
and hit the way you used to you want to
find those guys who were wired where you
just have to flip the switch right and
they're going to go out and do it they
don't need to practice it it's who they
are they don't need to be coaxed to go
out and hit someone in the mouth they
embrace it they love it they live for it
and if you can spot guys like that from
among that haystack of prospects and if
you can find the ones who are going to
come in and get it done uh
you're going to get it done and we're
done for the first hour of the program
coming up in hour two we're going to
take a look at the next team on our
preseason power rankings the jets at 24.
we're going to have a draft of offensive
rookie of the year candidates now that
clyde edward tulare is in a position to
get a lot of opportunities in kansas
city and also we're going to play some
of my chat from yesterday with falcons
quarterback matt ryan all that more
coming up in the next hour pft live
we'll be back with more right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports